this is goodie bag number nine
in today's video we will be exploring
the topics of polymerization and
crosslinking and learning how these
processes can be used to make slime at
home
you'll need gloves elmer's glue borax
powder
plastic cups and spoons for stirring
one product made of polymers that many
people are familiar with is silly putty
silly putty is made of a polymer called
polydimethyl ciloxane
polydimethylsiloxane is made of
repeating units called monomers that
include a silicon
an oxygen and two ch3 groups
today we're going to make an alternative
material that behaves a little bit like
silly putty but is instead made of a
different polymer
this can be made by combining elmer's
glue and crosslinking with borax
as you can see after i added borax to
the elmer's glue the material became
much more viscous
this is because of crosslinking
cross-linking is forming a bond
to link one polymer chain to another in
this experiment the polyvinyl alcohol in
elmer's glue
forms hydrogen bonds with the boric acid
these cross links make it more difficult
for the polymer chains to slide past one
another so the material becomes
more viscous by adding in more borax we
increase the number of crosslinks and
this results in a material more
resistant to flow
you may have noticed that when we pull
quickly this line breaks in half
but when we pull slowly the slime is
able to stretch this is because the slow
pulling allows hydrogen bonds to break
and then reform
allowing the chains to more easily slide
past one another
in this goody bag we hope you had an
opportunity to make a polymer of your
own
and witness how crosslinking can change
material properties